>> Sean: DEMOCRATS QUID PRO
QUO, NOW IT'S BRIBERY, THE
NARRATIVE COLLAPSING -- NOW
THEY'VE SHIFTED TO BRIBERY FROM
QUID PRO QUO BUT FACTS ARE
GETTING IN THE WAY.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN LINDSEY GRAHAM -- I'VE
BEEN ASKING YOUR COLLEAGUES,
FEDERAL RULES AS IT RELATES TO
THE ADMISSION OF EVIDENCE, IT IS
NOT GOING TO BE ALLOWED IN THE
SENATE AND THEY ALL SAY THE SAME
THING, NO.
THAT WOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED IN
THE SENATE, WHO DECIDES THAT?
WILL THAT BE THE SENATE MAKING
THOSE RULES OR WOULD IT BE THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT THAT WOULD
PRESIDE?
>> IT WOULD BE THE SENATE, THE
RESOLUTION HAS TO BE PASSED BY
51 VOTES SETTING THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF THE TRIAL, IT HAS
TO BE DONE BY SENATE RESOLUTION.
WHAT I WOULD INSIST UPON IS THE
FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE APPLY
TO THE CASE IN THE HOUSE, SO
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEFENSE
TEAM COULD OBJECT TO HEARSAY AND
95% OF THE TESTIMONY FALLS, THE
OTHER THING I WANT IS THE
ABILITY TO CONFRONT ONE'S
ACCUSERS BECAUSE IF YOU CALL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN THE SENATE, I
THINK YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
THAT.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO CONFRONT
YOUR ACCUSER IS BASICALLY DUE
PROCESS.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT TO THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
I WOULD THINK THAT IS
FUNDAMENTAL, I WOULD IMAGINE THE
CHIEF JUSTICE WOULD PRESIDE OVER
THIS AND ALLOW HEARSAY EVIDENCE
THAT IS NOT ADMISSIBLE IN TERMS
OF FEDERAL LAW.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE CHIEF
JUSTICE IS
JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME COURT
WOULD GO ALONG WITH THE
UNAMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE.
>> YOU HAVE TO SET THE RULES FOR
THE TRIAL, I DON'T THINK
DEMOCRATS -- IS IT TOO MUCH TO
ASK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP BE
GIVEN THE SAME RIGHTS AS EVERY
OTHER AMERICAN IN A PARKING
TICKET CASE?
YOU CAN'T GET A PARKING TICKET
BASED ON HEARSAY AND YOU ARE
ABLE TO CONFRONT THE PERSON
ACCUSING YOU OF ILLEGAL PARKING?
THOSE BASIC THINGS HAVE TO BE IN
THE TRIAL RESOLUTION I BELIEVE
AND I HOPE WE CAN GET 51 VOTES
FOR THE IDEA I JUST EXPRESSED.
>> Sean: YOU SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING OVER THERE, I CAN'T
GET OVER THE ARGUMENTS THEY ARE
TRYING TO MAKE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, WHEN WE READ THE
TRANSCRIPT, EVERYBODY -- WE ARE
INTERVIEWING PEOPLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE TRANSCRIPT THAT WE ALL
GET TO READ OURSELVES AND WHAT
THEY THINK OF THE TRANSCRIPT --
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY
THINK IN THE END ABOUT THE
TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE WE SEE THE
TRANSCRIPT, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
UKRAINE DID NOTHING AND THEY GOT
THE MONEY, THEY DID NOTHING.
WE ALSO KNOW THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE SAID FIVE TIMES, NO
PRESSURE.
WE DO HAVE THE ISSUE OF THE
BIDENS, I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
WITH THAT HYPOCRISY HERE.
HOW DO THEY ALL SAY "NOBODY OF
CREDIBILITY HAS EVER SAID
THERE'S ANYTHING WRONG HERE."
>> NOBODY'S LOOKED, NOBODY'S
LOOKED.
>> Sean: I'M LOOKING, AND WHAT
I SEE IS REALLY BAD.
THE VERY THING THEY ARE GETTING
OUTRAGED ABOUT, JOE BIDEN IS
ADMITTING A BILLION DOLLARS,
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR, YOU DON'T
GET THE BILLION IF YOU DON'T,
HIS SON GETS MILLIONS AND HE
ACTUALLY SAID NO EXPERIENCE
WHATSOEVER, NONE, ZERO.
>> HERE'S THE ARGUMENT,
JOE BIDEN WAS ASKING THE
PROSECUTOR TO BE FIRED BECAUSE
HIS PROSECUTOR WAS CORRUPT.
>> Sean: I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> ALL OF THESE PHONE CALLS THAT
TOOK PLACE BETWEEN BIDEN AND
THEN PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, MOST
OF THEM OCCURRED AFTER THE RAID
ON THE GAS COMPANY BY THE
PROSECUTOR.
>> Sean: SLOW DOWN, I WANT
EVERYONE TO HEAR YOU.
THE PHONE CALLS THAT TOOK PLACE
BETWEEN THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE AND JOE BIDEN RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME THIS IS
HAPPENING -- WAIT A MINUTE, ARE
THERE TRANSCRIPTS OF THOSE CALL
CALLS?
>> HERE'S WHAT SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
ASK -- JOE BIDEN AT THE UKRAINE
PORTFOLIO, ABOUT EVERY MONTH HE
WOULD CALL UKRAINE BUT AFTER THE
RAID ON THE GAS COMPANY WHERE
HUNTER BIDEN WAS A BOARD MEMBER,
THEY RATED THE PRESIDENT OF THE
GAS COMPANY'S HOME.
AFTER THAT YOU SEE ABOUT THREE
OR FOUR PHONE CALLS AND FOUR OR
FIVE DAYS BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, THEN
YOU SEE THE CASE DROPPED.
YOU ALSO SEE HUNTER BIDEN'S
BUSINESS PARTNERS CONTACTING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE RAID ON THE GAS
COMPANY IN SAYING THIS COULD
AFFECT HUNTER BIDEN.
I WANT SOMEBODY TO LOOK INTO
THAT.
>> Sean: I WANT THE
TRANSCRIPTS RELEASED, I WANT THE
PUTIN-OBAMA TRANSCRIPTS RELEASE
RELEASED.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU A QUESTION
HERE, DECEMBER 11TH,
MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
THAT MEANS WE ARE GOING TO GET